[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside the man
the myth the legend sam richmond
this weekend is all star weekend so we
got a lot to talk about sam
and also sam we're giving away an iphone
13
right here on this show sam this is your
second time on now you're no longer a
rookie did you bring the locks for us
today
always greg you you hyped me up so much
i i couldn't do anything but that i can
never let you down so yes we are going
to win we are going to win big tonight i
love it
we are going to win and we are going to
win big sam is sending us and giving us
the good vibes the good juju but sam i
want to know
we're giving away a lot of iphone 13s
i've yet to
to go and get an iphone 13
do you by any chance have one already
no i don't i'm glad you brought that
upgrade because i was i was gonna flag
that are are the co-hosts eligible and
if not i would like to have a long
conversation with our lead producer max
after the show because i want to know
like i'm jealous of the audience
i'm jealous too bro we got to figure out
how we can get some of these iphone 13s
but as always we're giving away locks
we're giving away hoodies we're giving
away jerseys and we are giving away that
iphone 13 so get in the comments i need
gifts i need emojis but most importantly
i need winners only please and matter of
fact i'm about to get into these
comments sam and give away a jersey
right now i see snoopy
snoopy two one five three gave us sunset
sam
they know the comments know sunsets is
the way to my heart so therefore snoopy
you are walking away with a jersey of
your choice sam let's get right to it
it's tnt basketball thursday which means
we are betting the three by two the
question is will there be two three
pointers in the first three minutes of
the game
there's only one game tonight sam on tnt
so we asked you on twitter are you
riding the bucks sixers 3x2 with us
tonight get in the comments drop your
text sam the 3x2 is boosted from -110 to
plus 120 do you like those odds
i mean it's what what's there to say
it's a boosted three by two of of course
i like it i'm just gonna go a step
further i'm gonna predict not only that
it hits but who catches it for us i'll
go danny green three i'll go chris
middleton three and that is how we catch
this tonight let's go
that is how we are catching this sam i
saw what you do what you did there you
are manifesting
you're actually mentioning names that
you think that are going to catch this
by two i like i see the good vibes i see
the juju and i like what you are doing
there let me uh hop into these comments
let me hop into these comments
because i'm giving away hoodies and also
we are giving away that iphone 13 and
maybe maybe i might give it away here
but i do not know i got jones jordan
jones jordan is rocking with us he says
yes he's rocking with us in the three by
two shout out to you jones jordan you're
walking away with a hoodie also uh oh
henry oh henry says the three by two
sounds legit oh henry you are also
walking away with the hoodie hey tj tj
is spamming us in the comments brother i
am here to tell you that is not how
you're going to get a hoodie by spam in
the comments give us good takes that is
how you guys are walking away with good
uh that's how you walk away with hoodies
but we are riding the milwaukee bucks
versus the 76ers three by two tonight
let's all get rick sam now let's talk
major markets money lines against the
spread and point totals for tonight's
game let's take a look at the odds sam
what are you seeing here and what do you
like
yeah so i bet this game i uh i really
like this bet i took the 76ers plus six
and a half
i think you could make the argument i
think people look at this game and you
know see for philly it's a road game
last game before the all-star break got
hardened coming back outside the
all-star break maybe they'll just look
ahead and kind of mail it in
i don't see that honestly i really like
this as a situational spot for philly
they just got blown out on tuesday by
the celtics on national tv i think that
means something like the fact that this
game is back on tnt national tv good
opportunity for them for to kind of
redeem themselves i think also a spot i
like here is just this is
the last maybe one of the last games for
embiid as the guy in a monster game
before hardin comes along i think as
someone who's making an mbp push he's
going to care about that he's going to
want to show out i could see him going
for 35 40 maybe and also you just look
at the bucks are missing about five to
six guys in their rotation i think the
focus is probably going to be on hey
philly doesn't have harden but philly
has most of their dudes the the bucks
don't so i think that country's up
within there you get six and a half
points with a really good sixers team
i'm all over it
yes sir i'm right there with you i am
right there with you the last time we
saw the 76ers team they they laid an egg
against those boston celtics on national
television i do not see that happening
again to a doc rivers team i do see them
going into milwaukee and playing a
competitive game and you mentioned that
bucks team is they're kind of beat up
some some guys are out it's philadelphia
76ers team they don't have james harden
but they still have
their team they still have that depth so
i see them bouncing back today give me
sixers plus the points i'm in the
comments though because i want to know
what they are talking about uh oh sam
look we got jake elston he says the
sixers are gonna lose but sam what we do
here on our shows is we show bad vibes
good vibes so my guys basically fading
us but with that being said jake you are
walking away with the hoodie brother i
hope that hoodie treats you well and i
hope the 76ers get a w tonight because
that means me and sam will be cashing
our bets uh i'm back into the comments
though sam i see bradyp 13 says dybal
will be clamping up middleton tonight
that's going to help us out sam so i
like that bradyp 13. you are also
walking away with the hoodie make sure
you guys stick around because we're
going to talk about some all-star
bets and we're giving out that iphone 13
but before we do that
we have to build the br betting same
game parlay
tonight we're looking at this bucks
sixers game and i need everybody and i
mean everybody to get in the comments
and tell me what they are thinking which
legs are locked which legs are not
sam let's get right to it we were just
talking about this man joe lmb has
absolutely been on a tear since january
it's the beginning of january he's been
on the tear his numbers have been
crazy i need him to get 30 tonight sam
i mean this seems like a layup if you go
look at joelle and beats numbers since
the beginning of january 30 points seems
like a layup do you like this one or do
you not
yeah like i like i said with with the
game pick i really like the spot for
embiid i think he cares about winning
mvp i think he realizes this is one of
the last times on a national televised
game that i'll probably be the only
superstar in my team i think he goes for
30 35 maybe more
sam is rocking with the joe l mb pick
starting off well let's move on to
giannis anthon takumpo we're not talking
points we're not talking to sis but we
are talking rebounds here sam can
giannis go out there and grab 10
rebounds tonight
yeah i think so i mean he's averaging
close to 12 this month again the bucks
are lacking some depth uh and some big
men in there too so it requires giannis
to kind of do a little bit more of the
dirty work so i think he gets there i
don't think it'll be much of a problem
okay okay okay i like the first two
picks but this pick right here uh
it just
i don't know i just don't know about it
but sam i hopefully you could talk me
out the way that i'm feeling we got
chris middleton to make two three
pointers only two sam only two do you
think my guy chris middleton can go out
there and knock down two three-pointers
tonight
so i was feeling
i feel good about this league this leg i
was feeling better before that commenter
talked about table locking up middleton
which is good for a sixers bet but bad
vibes for this look uh
i think middleton has kind of struggled
from the three-point line recently but i
think the thing that i like here is that
even if he's not making these shots he's
still getting them up you look at his
last few games you have a one for eight
you have a one for six as long as he's
shooting seven or eight threes i think
he's gonna hit two i mean he's he's
around he's a lot better than what is a
25 percent free throw shooter sorry
three-point shooter so uh if he takes
seven or eight of these i think he's
he's getting two in
my man sam is over there crunching down
the numbers we're live and he's
crunching down the numbers as he speaks
uh middleton to go over two three
pointers uh
we're sending the good vibes for that
but let's move on to his point guard his
point guard and we're not talking assist
we're talking points here with drew
holiday to go over 15 points sam talk to
me
talk to me nice do you like this leg of
the parlay
yeah he's averaging 19 points this month
he's had a few games one was in the 23
range he's gotten over 20 a handful of
times so
you know i think i think holiday hits i
think giannis and b definitely it it's
the middleton i'm so focused on the
middleton if we can get that second
three i think that's going to be the
difference here but i think holiday gets
it done
but you you mentioned as long as he's
putting up those shots man we really
can't be mad at that as long as the
shots is getting put up hey we're taking
our chances on this bet so we'll see uh
but what i want to see right now sam is
if we were to put a hundred dollars down
how much money will we be walking away
with let's pull up the tickets so we can
in fact show you that right now if you
guys were to put a hundred dollars down
you're walking away with 427 dollars in
eight
cents
go put this in
go get rich hey
sam but before i get into the comments
what are you grading the same game
parlor
i love when you asked me to grade the
parlay that i helped build so obviously
i'm going to give it an a i'm honestly
like like i said i'm always going to
give a partly build it built in hey i'm
more curious what you would grade it
greg what are you putting this at
sam uh
i love your parlay brother you you know
i think that you're a sharp i think that
you're one of the best bettors on the br
betting staff i love your parlay but
there's just been this thing and i don't
know what it is but liv gives us b
minuses bro and we hate we hit like no
every time she gives us a b minus we
usually hit so i'm going to continue
those trends continue that juju my heart
wants to give it an a but my mind's
telling me to give it a b minus because
i actually want to see this one go
through the net so i'm giving it a b
minus say i'm rocking with you i'm
giving it a b minus but let me get to
these comments though sam because i got
to see what they are talking about and
i'm giving away hoodies i'm also giving
away a jersey i got san francis 100 says
30 plus is a lock and the sixers going
to bounce back from that celtics ale
gave us a joel and b gift san francis i
am sending you a hoodie of your choice i
love that take also uh
enderman is in the comments enderman
also always gives us good takes and b
gonna get over 30 points iannis is gonna
get that easy ten plus rebounds
middleton will drain three threes and
finish with 20 plus points drew will get
over 15. don't see him getting anything
less winners only place enderman
appreciate you for those good vibes
you're walking away with a video i got i
guess i gotta give
away this jersey sam i gotta give this
jersey away and uh
i see
i see
jack costa jack costa he gave us the a
minus just because of those goodbyes
jack you are walking away with a jersey
of your choice all right sam it's time
to talk the all-star game the game is
sunday at
eight on tnt but the three-point contest
is saturday night and i cannot wait
let's take a look at the odds sam
what do you like no actually not what
but who do you like to win the
three-point contest this year
yeah i think this is a really
interesting three-point contest more so
than past years where you had the staffs
or even a few years back the clays of
the world who were always like plus 125
plus 200 like this is a completely wide
open field um and i feel i think that's
right i feel like this is kind of a crap
shoot so i'm going to look closer to the
bottom of the list i'm taking luke
canard plus 600 he's like fifth in the
league and three-point percentage he has
the best three-point percentage of
anyone in this field so uh at plus 600
i'll take my chance with canard why not
i like that picks sam uh luke kanarkin
he has the burner he has the fireball
from the left and he's a lefty so i like
that but uh i'm with you at sticking
towards the bottom of the list but i
want to go to the very very bottom and
that is carl anthony towns
for the people that don't know carl
anthony towns is one of the best big man
shooting centers in nba history he's one
of the best
and i think he's going to go out there
in cleveland and put on a show and it's
plus 1200 sam it's plus 1200 on the coin
flip give me my man cat
uh to go win this one but i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments giving away
hoodies because i want to see who they
are rocking with uh oh henry 69 says
canard is fire so shout out to you oh
henry you are walking away with a hoodie
i also see reload reload says trae young
for me cj is also a dark horse shout out
to you rilo you are walking away with a
hoodie uh i'll leave the comments alone
because we're about to talk slam dunk
contest now let's take a look at the
current odds sam who do you like
to win the slam dunk contest brother
yeah this is this is a really tough feel
because everyone feels so close i'll
take cole anthony plus 250. um i think
he has some some nice hype around him
he's been a really fun player the last
two years
guards usually win this uh smaller
guards usually win this so he fits the
mode so uh he just seems like a big game
player i think he'll want to shot on
this so i'm taking cole anthony i'm more
curious for your pick though because if
your history repeats itself here you are
going to take jta from the warriors
which i'm really interested here because
i don't think anyone else is taking that
am i right there are you taking to scott
anderson
i'm only gonna sprinkle jta simply
because he has the draymond endorsement
i firmly believe draymond's not just
gonna endorse anybody i know draymond i
know the type of guy that he is he's
just not gonna go out there and say
anything about anybody if he doesn't
believe they could actually go out there
and do something so he said one jta can
go out there and win so i'll sprinkle
something on jta but i'm here to tell
the people that's watching what i saw
with my own two eyes last year at the
summer league sam and that was obi topic
my guy was
going absolutely bananas in pregame
warm-ups as far as dunking the ball is
his head was touching the rim he was
three sixties and he was he was doing it
all he was doing it all and this was in
warm-ups before he played the game sam
he's not gonna play a game saturday
night he's gonna have some some decent i
know he's playing the season but decent
fresh legs
so my guy i'll be topping that plus 200
i think i want to rock that way sam but
i'm in the comments right now let me hop
in these comments because i want to see
what they're talking about and i got
officially cut says jalen green one of
my favorite players and the man be
floating with the clouds shout out to
you officially cut you are walking away
with a hoodie also i see uh
i see elle davis damar winning all-star
mvp well we're not there yet l davis but
uh shout out to you for commenting i see
easy defeat says top and die hard knicks
fans
here coming out to dominate he's rocking
with my pick shout out to you easy
defeat you are also walking away with a
hoodie sam let's move on we're still
talking all-star game let's talk major
markets
for the all-star game let's take a look
at the odds sam what do you like are you
team katie or are you team lebron
i mean look
the team lebron roster is
significantly better than the team
durant roster like it's really not at a
close
that said i'm i'm taking the six points
with team grant this isn't a real
basketball game this is an exhibition
game where the talent difference doesn't
actually matter i mean all these guys
are really really good so i'll take the
six points i think this game is meant to
be fun blowouts aren't fun i think the
players know that i think the all-star
game two years ago where it came down to
the wire was a lot more
exciting than the one last year i think
i think the players know that i think
it'll be a close game so i'll just take
the six points uh and see what happens
i like that sam i don't dislike the bet
but i just don't know if i can bet the
six points i'm looking at that totals
him i'm looking at that total
hey i'm rocking with the over man i know
it's at 3 3 19 and a half but hey give
it to me i am rocking with the over they
usually they don't play defense in these
all-star games no one wants to get hurt
i'm taking my chances on a lot of
buckets a lot of three-point shots put
the ball in the basket uh but i'm in the
comments right now i'm in the comments
giving away hoodies i see
go garden is in the comments go garden
is in the comments broad team is better
but think katie
and co will be style katie and company
will be styled shout out to you go
garden you walk away with a hoodie uh m
kent 93 says team minus six all day
rocking with team lebron shout out to
you m kent you are also walking away
with the hoodie sam
my man l davis mentioned all-star mvp a
couple segments ago but now we're here
it's time to give away that iphone as
well today we asked you in the app who
is your lock to win all star mvp let's
take a look at the current knocks sam
who do you like
to win all-star mvp yeah this is so fun
like this is this is the most fun bed of
the weekend uh and i think the guy i'm
taking is gonna be really fun too i'm
taking john moran plus 850. to me this
is like this is the year of job this is
a really good opportunity for his like
coming out party as like an official
top-tier nba superstar he has the best
highlights of anyone in the league right
now you can't go to br house of
highlights and not see him there every
single night he's just an absolute freak
of an athlete i think he'll probably
care about this game more than some of
the older vets who've been there done
that this is just like a huge john
marant showcase and i think he uh
finishes it off by winning all-star mvp
and he's on team kd so he goes with my
pick as well so
i like i like that sam i like that pick
a lot josh uh ja not josh but john
marant uh he got those young legs you
know he got those young legs in this
all-star game he might be a little bit
springy out there but i do want to talk
about lebron james
going back to cleveland
let's just let that sink in a little bit
this might be lebron james last game
in cleveland for the all-star game this
might be his last all-star game in
cleveland in his career and my man's
going home i can see my man lebron james
putting up some numbers it's his last
time
in cleveland potentially for the
all-star sam he's been putting the ball
in the bucket all year he's been putting
the ball in the bucket why can't he do
it in the all-star game i'm rocking
lebron
to win mvp but i'm in the comments right
now i'm in the comments because i'm
giving away hoodies but i'm also giving
away that iphone 13 and if i see a good
takes uh sam i'm just gonna give away
that iphone i see jojo four seven three
four five four says i'm taking lebron
james he's back to cleveland taking that
win and mvp easy shout out to you jojo
you're rocking with me i'm sending you a
hoodie i also see bucks will win giannis
will win and i will be fine if he wins
the mvp let's go greek freak shout out
to you bucks will win you are walking
away with a hoodie munch money muncher
tan says giannis was very competitive
last time
and his team is gonna win money muncher
you
are walking away
with the iphone 13 i like i like your
take i like your take you brought up
last year you brought up a man giannis
dominating last year having a good game
you think he'll do it again and they'll
get the win you are walking away with
that iphone 13 sam
let's move on because we know
i know and if you guys don't know at
home now you know if you want to talk
futures
talk futures with my man sam sam you
love talking futures and all star break
is a good time to lock in some final
futures let's take a look at the current
odds to win it all sam are you still
holding on to that jazz future that you
once talked about
and if so or if not what else do you
like now
[Music]
yeah no i mean i like shout out fanduel
yeah i mean last time i was on the show
i gave out the jazz in the future but
the great thing about fanduel uh is you
can cash out your bet so when the jazz
went on a losing streak and i started
believing them they'll believing in them
a little bit less i just cashed it out
and now you know if i see an opportunity
to reinvest in them at a higher number i
can but i moved on from the jazz i took
the i did take another future i took the
76ers at plus 1400 right when the
hardening trade before the line moved so
uh that was great so i'm just going to
keep riding with that 76ers they're plus
650. look i think harder was miserable
in brooklyn i think he's going to be
energized and philly embiid as we've
talked about you've said it just been on
an absolute freaking tear
since the start of the year that combo
in the pick and roll is absolutely
lethal they didn't lose a lot of depth
in the trade uh so i like six first plus
650 i think this is the year for uh for
hardin to be to get it done
i like that sam i actually like that a
lot but i do want to talk about
something i've been talking about the
whole year since the beginning of the
year i've been rocking with the golden
state warriors
to win the championship and we see that
they're one of the favorites here i
still want you guys
to lock that in because it's going up
it's at plus 460 now i mean if you guys
want to sprinkle it lock that in do not
be alarmed by the recent turmoil the
recent struggles that they've been going
through i just think that they need to
have some fresh legs get some guys back
iggy draymond and wiseman back
uh to the lineup and the golden state
warriors will be just fine as far as in
competing for a championship but if i
was to sprinkle something else in if i
was to go
in another direction
this trade that just happened last week
brooklyn 76ers i'll say the brooklyn
nets won the trade sam they won the
trade they got ben simmons they got
traffic they got my guy seth curry i
would say overall they won the trade
the 76ers they got james harden and
james harden
mixed up with joel embiid running the
pick-and-roll offense with doc rivers as
the coach oh my that is a scary scary
sight for the east katie and company you
guys better watch out giannis and
company you guys better watch out plus
650 last week i said it and it was plus
1100 it went down to plus 650 for a
reason sam
i'm right there with you brother i like
the 76ers uh if i was to go away from
the warriors i do like the 76ers but let
me hop into these comments sam let me
hop into these comments because i'm
giving away jerseys and i'm also giving
away hoodies
and i see
jhurn 23 says giannis has got to be the
favorite to win the all-star game mvp
his style of flav his style of play fits
perfectly with the all-star game so he
will put up a ton of points
catching lobs fast breaks points easy
layups and points in the paint he's on
lebron's team and they always win
and have the clear advantage this year
so giannis is the great odds to win
all-star game mvp give me the freak hey
jay hearn that was an a plus
a plus plus take appreciate you you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice and i'm sending you a hoodie just
for the take loved it uh i'm moving on
emco blue is in the comments he says
nets for the title shout out to um go
blue hey walker also in the comments
says yes to the bulls winning the
championship at plus 3 000 shout out to
uk walker you are walking away with a
hoodie sam and i got one more hoodie in
me my boy mike bowling is in the
comments what up mike he's talking about
the bulls g clan 26 says hell yes sixers
going all the way and the suns won't
stop and beat in the paint
there it is uh you were walking away
with a hoodie g quinn but sam
we reached the end brother we have
reached the end i want to thank
everybody that's here it's in the
comments giving us good takes thank you
guys for tapping in to the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
we are all riding the bucks sixers 3x2
as a family get on fanduel and tail or
beat our betting same game early
follow us all weekend long for all star
locks we'll be back next thursday giving
out more hoodies more locks more jerseys
and if you want a hoodie today
we will dm you
alongside the man the myth the legend
sam richmond i'm greg ivory we are
leaving
the group chat
peace peace
[Music]
foreign